I am here at the University of Sydney
where the mechanical engineering shop
has built this incredible piece of
apparatus for me it is a 40 pound that
is 19 kilogram flywheel on the end of a
meter long shaft can you imagine trying
to hold this out horizontally with just
one hand at this end it is virtually it
is impossible okay now I'm gonna let go
you gonna be able to hold this at all
I've shot can you lift it out make your
horizontal hold it hold it hold it
come on just try it I want you to hold
it out horizontal see if you can go with
it oh come on hmm what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to spin this up to a few
thousand rpm and then I'm going to
attempt just that hold it from one end
and have it out horizontally
301
when a lick go of my left hand what
you'll see is that the shaft remains
horizontal and see it going around there
it almost looks as though the wheel is
weightless how does this work
well instead of pulling the wheel down
to the ground as you'd expect the weight
of the wheel creates a torque which
pushes it around in a circle you may
recognize this as gyroscopic precession
for a more detailed explanation click
the annotation or the link in the
description to see my video on the topic
here I want to try something more
extreme I'm going to try to lift it over
my head with one hand while it's
spinning
wish me luck but before I make the
attempt rod wisely suggests that I first
check if I can lift the wheel above my
head without it spinning let's prove
that I can lift it just this end without
it spinning here we go ah how I mean
it's just kind of awkward at the hand
okay oh just barely
oh goodness do you even lift ah clearly
I do not unde anted by my lack of
strength I'm going for it but I want to
make sure that the wheel is spinning as
fast as possible to give me the best
chance of success get a 10 more side of
pen
eight seven six five four
oh that was perfect now I'm going to
release my left hand and holding only
with my right hand at the end of the
shaft I'll try to lift it up over my
head this is a 40 pound 19 kilogram
flywheel ready here we go three two one
beautiful let's go again in three two
one
nice five three two one it feels
incredibly incredibly light as I do that
you
when you said it felt incredibly live
yeah when you're lifting it feels like
yeah shouldn't I know honestly I have
lifted it up with one hand when it's not
spinning yeah and it feels really hard
to lift it up like it's big effort yeah
but with this when it's spinning it
honestly felt like it was just wanting
to go up by itself yes it felt like I
was not struggling like I was not
putting in the amount of force that you
think to lift that kind of weight I'll
bet if you let it go it would crush down
to the ground
it's not like we can't do that though we
can't do that part of the experiment
what we could maybe do is I could stand
on a scale we could see what the weight
of me Plus that apparatus does while I'm
lifting it up over my head see if I get
lighter in essence you can see that just
my weight is about 72 kilograms now when
I pick up the flywheel it goes up to
about 91 kilograms which makes sense
because the flywheel itself is about 19
kilos that's 42 pounds now we're going
to spin it up and I want you to make a
prediction as I'm lifting it over my
head
do you think the scale reading will be
more less than or equal to 91 kilograms
what do you think you can make your
prediction by clicking on one of the
on-screen annotations or if you're on
mobile you can click a link in the
description five four three two one
horse
you